hahaha
mais c'est quoi ton rapport avec
l'afrique
[Musique]
oh
une eau mag est ok mais pourquoi
directement me dire mais c'était
difficile en fait non pourquoi le loyer
ce serait difficile c'est un pays en
fait j'ai pas alors femme noire qui
utilisent de l'argot en plus elle est
normal in home a dit à l'ats ferrand
sont avec une africaine un exotique
silva faut qu'on lui parle de la frite
c'est sûr que ces genres pour être
simple
[Musique]
alors quand on sort mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que ça fait d'être genre où
l'une des premières renoir est rodé
charte mais de quoi tu me paraissent
quoi le rapport entre ma musique est ma
couleur
alors pourquoi tu n'existes pas en fait
s'il ya des artistes jaurès on blonde
assez brute façon bêtises on leur dit
pas simple mais pourquoi monsieur que
cette question quand je suis revenue je
parlais pas de ma couleur
je peux te dire hors et je suis là au
loin je vais tout péter non je n'ai pas
dit ça plus chez moi quand je parle de
fin quand je vais dans des plateaux où
je vais au studio je vais être ma voix
france et juste ça tu vois je vois pas
de l'artiste de rappeurs chanteurs ou à
leur sort les trucs comme ça
[Musique]
quelques questions en verve hier grave
mais rémy née chez pas en vrai j'ai
l'impression une femme qui s'assume qui
dit ce qu'elle pense eh ben c'est une
femme qui fait la rebelle à l'est
féminisme mais un homme quand je dis la
même chose maintenant on va lui il est
normal que y'a pas de soucis je mets en
vrai ça se trouve que je que c'est
c'est ça qui fait qu'il ya plein de meuf
qui m'écoutent tu vois peut-être que
c'est bon caractère qu'il est en
directement même moi je ne sais pas ça
se trouve tu vois la femme noire n'est
pas comme ça l info qu'elle soit
naturelle quand elle mais il faut je
veux en gros c'est qu'elle sait que sm
pallem pas ses cheveux non en vrai ça se
trouve la meuf elle a juste envie de
prendre soin de ses voeux alors envie de
faire ses petites nappes hyper je vois
c'est en gros ce qui est sûr c'est
vraiment un plaisir en fait quand on
fait quand tu mets ça ça coûte cher
c'est pas gratuit
en vrai c'est pas gratuit tu vois c'est
quoi c'est pas son euro se trouve ma
perruque et coûte plus cher que des
chaussures tu vois ce que je veux dire
on faisait ça le truc